it's not all it's got one more thing to
share with everyone
and it's safe social
and sustainable and what am i talking
about
well no other project hazel
we announced this at ces earlier this
year
and at ces we had some truly
truly insane press coverage with
everyone
out there saying when can i get a
project hazel will you
make it into reality and it wasn't just
the press
we had resounding response from the
community
every single one asking us to make
project hazel a reality
and many of you had great ideas
ideas for features features to remove
we've heard your feedback we continue to
hear your feedback
on twitter on facebook ping us anytime
because we listen to all the feedback
for gamers
by gamers and what i thought i would do
today
is that i'd give everyone an update on
the project
because we are going to be making
project hazel a reality
so what kind of updates can we give well
when the pandemic first started we
converted one of our
manufacturing facilities to make
surgical masks today
we at razer make high quality
certified surgical masks and we ship
them worldwide
we've donated over a million mosques
worldwide in the u.s
in europe in asia in africa etc
and we continue to do that high quality
surgical masks meeting the very best
standards
and what we've done is that we've taken
the learnings from that
the engineering the design and we've put
that
into project hazel so project hazel is
going to be using
replaceable n95 grade filters
we've now designed in a secure silicon
face seal
these are just some some of the updates
since the last
time that we talked about this at ces
and we are going to make sure
that project hazel follows the lab
testing
with bfe rating that we've done for
surgical masks
that's the safe aspect now what about
the social aspect what are we keeping
what are we not keeping
well first up the clear transparent
design
we're definitely keeping that we're also
adding in
interior lighting so that in low light
conditions you can still see the face
of the project hazel user and one of the
big things that we've added
this time around is anti-fog coating
so we've got an anti-fog coating on the
inside of the project hazel
to ensure that the social function
still remains even during use
now what about sustainability now many
of you will be aware sustainability is
at the core of what we do
over here at razer we care a lot about
the environment
one of the things that concerned us the
most when we were making these one-off
surgical masks was the sustainability of
the surgical masks well project hazel
has got a reusable mask design and
every single filter lasts three times
longer
than single-use surgical masks and what
i'm really proud to say is that
every filter uses 80 percent less
material
than traditional surgical masks now i'm
sure many of you
are waiting to try out project hazel and
i'm going to talk about availability
at the end of this but if you can't wait
to try project hazel out we've got
something really special for all of you
you can try
the project hazel filter online and see
how it looks on your face you can check
it out on instagram
check out razer and here's a quick video
to show how you can use
the project hazel filter on insta
[Music]
now remember to tag us with your project
hazel filters
because we will be watching out for all
of you and we might have some pretty
cool giveaways
for project hazel when the time comes
for shipping
so we've got a quick video to show you
the updates that we've made
since the last time we announced this at
ces here you go
[Music]
so i'm sure many of you are asking when
can i get one
when do they ship well with the insane
demand
that we're expecting for project hazel
we've put together a plan
so that we can get as many of these
units out to you as possible
we're gonna have limited quantities
right from the get-go so once we start
manufacturing
we're gonna be doing sale by drops we'll
have all the database of everybody who
wants a project hazel
and we'll send you information once
there are units available
and our first drop is going to be
happening
early q4 we're still perfecting it
we're taking in all the beta feedback
you're going to see
units out in the field but the first
drop is going to happen
early q4 once we've got most of the
testing and certification done
and it's going to be available
exclusively on razer.com
and you can sign up now for all the
information at rzr
dot to backslash project
hazel so thank you very much for joining
us here today